hello i'm michael mizurik i am a
vegetable breeder in the field of plant
breeding here at cornell and the crops i
focus on are cucurbits
squash we'll be talking about today
watermelons melons cucumbers i also work
on peppers
and also have some growing interest in
peas and bean
and india as i talk say that i'm a
vegetable breeder and i listed off a lot
of crops there's even a lot more than
that of course that are in the seed
catalog in the mail for your garden
um
refers to most of the produce section
fruits and vegetables that's the entire
produce section and so i say that they
pointed out that we count vegetable
breeders
in the u.s especially
public sector vegetable breeders at
universities that are creating the
genetics germplasm student training
and releasing cultivars of pre-breeding
materials as we consider us as just
vegetable breeders it seems like there's
a lot
but we actually have quite a shortage
and so as you think about cucumbers uh
to my knowledge i'm the last
cucumber breeder
in the u.s is producing
cultivars for the the seed industry a
lot of great research collaborators for
sure
second to last for squash
and there's other quite a few crops
where
we really uh could i could use some
colleagues in i have the great fortune
to also work in bean where that larger
community is also just a fantastic group
to collaborate with and
so my my plug to let's figure out how to
help build this in all the vegetables
the crop i'm going to focus on today and
i'm i've done most of my work on uh so
good for a focus today is squash
and within squash there's three species
we work on there's cucurbita maxima so
if you're familiar with
butter cup squash kabocha squash blue
hubbard squash those would be the
maximus species also the giant world
record pumpkins are maximas there's also
cucurbita people that's really diverse
and gets the most investment of the
otherwise rather
under-resourced cucurbita species
cucurbited people include zucchini
delicata acorn jack-o-lantern pumpkins
there's a lot of diversity there
the crop that
is the third major crop in the u.s
there's other crops eaten globally is
cucurbita moshada this is a rather
tropical squash
they tend to have day link sensitivities
they uh have short day squash
they tend to be grown and found in
equatorial regions they need much more
heat units to really ripen and mature in
general
but the other great thing for me as i've
started to work on them is for someone
like me in the middle of new york state
if i start working with these now and in
collaboration with some rei organic
research extension initiative projects
we've had
we can link
uh what our
breeding work is in new york to
what the problems are on the ground for
sustainable ecological growers tennessee
and south all the way down to the
southern coast
so that we can see what are people doing
to combat
climate change related changes uh now
what are the challenges they have on
their farm and incorporate it into
our cultivars today is i'm always trying
to predict the future we're always
looking ahead a few years and for me as
we look at as our growing zones
become warmer growing zones what that
means to me is the pests and pathogens
of more southerly zones will be moving
north and
a way to get ahead of that is i'm
looking ahead in my crystal ball to what
should i have developed 10 years from
now
is going to be looking to see what
people are
dealing with in a climate south of us
so the big challenges they face
uh among many but the ones that kind of
are relevant to what i'll share
is
it's
we can pick on our winters our gray days
in ithaca uh it doesn't make for a great
light for a photo shoot though doesn't
it and
right but we have our freezing winter is
an agricultural reset so all the pests
and pathogens get wiped out the season
ends we stop growing the host plants and
we go into the spring we're really
starting fresh with a blank slate with
all the accumulated
biotic stresses
wiped clean
south of us
in the southeastern u.s they don't have
that luxury of winter really as much to
kind of wipe the slate clean
so when they try to grow some other
squash like cucurbita pepo or maxima
you know we grow so much zucchini it's
really challenging to grow there the
cucurbita pepo because it's vulnerable
to all the threats
cucurbita moshada is
much less vulnerable because it's coming
from tropical regions of the world where
it has to deal with these pests and
pathogens year round
and so as cucurbita dispersed from its
centers of origins in the americas to
being
having all these global iterations and
his cultures reinterpreting it to their
cuisine their culture their growing
region we have all these great secondary
centers where people have reselected the
cucurbits we know so in the u.s when you
think of kikura moshada uh the the one
you're probably familiar with is
butternut squash
it has a relative on the caribbean
calabazza squash tropical pumpkin
is another name for it so that's
commonly grown there
when
these squashes and arrived in europe
they made it down to italy and were
reselected for other traits so our
butternut squash in
italy one of the variations became this
trombonchino and so a tromboncino squash
can also work as a winter squash a
mature squash like a butternut it also
works immature kind of like a zucchini
stage but it's much tastier because the
seed we have all the moisture is in this
seed ball at the end like what butternut
squash would be
it has this exaggerated neck that's
actually very
dense tissue that has a much better
flavor than a zucchini it has much more
food than a zucchini it's less watery
and
it tastes great and different than
butternut squash and that when we would
take this we'll slice it a light brine
and then sear it it's really delicious
and i didn't know that until i started
working with some chefs that helped open
my eyes to how they were cooking it and
probably how many people in italy were
working with it
the growers in the southeast
would love growing this squash they were
telling me as i talked about my work in
zucchini cucumber to people they're like
yeah but if you can defeat one pest all
the other insects will wipe it out
so
cucurbitomoshada has a solid stem unlike
eukaryotic people the hollow stem they
can get full of vine borers
and so they will take out that squash
you heard of moshada naturally resistant
has a solid stem it doesn't have that
hollow area for the insects to get
inside and stay inside and eventually
kill the plant from the inside
what they asked me for
and i think the many of the chefs would
agree is this is a very fanciful squash
very fun to grow in your garden but if
you have many of them in a harvest crate
as you pull them out of the harvest
crate you'll break them
and that's no good going to market so
what we've been doing here is working on
something that's a little bit more of a
practical shape for the grower we've
been including a lot of our great
disease resistances that i was able to
inherit from my predecessors henry
munger and molly john that both worked
on these crops
at cornell combine it with a really high
quality winter squash breeding line we
are had already bred in collaboration
with chefs to be delicious and really
rich and savory and then we combined
that with the heirloom trombonchino and
the plots i'm saying here are that mix
where we're really close to releasing
our second generation of these squash
where
we have some of them serve a bit of a
curve we're getting some great flavors
we are really interested in why these
taste so much better immature than a
butternut squash does so what's going on
with the carbohydrates inside
and also how can we bring in some more
modern approaches now that we have some
a really good breeding base of materials
we consider now elite semi-elite now i
think it's at a stage where we can bring
in some
interesting genomic tools that we now
have in cucurbits largely thanks to
q-cap
and we have
um can look at questions related to how
can we select for a low heritability
trait like what makes us have the curve
in the first place
so thanks for coming out to my squash
patch
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu